[Música]
gonzalo gran josé luis cardoso juan
carlos serrudo tres bolivianos que el 24
de noviembre del 2007 salieron a
protestar por lo que ellos creían
correcto en la capital de bolivia sucre
yo tenía 13 años y aún recuerdo el miedo
que sentí al darme cuenta de que habían
protestas masivas en toda mi ciudad
natal y que no sólo fueron estas tres
personas fallecidas el saldo de las
protestas sino más de 400 heridos
algunos de los cuales inclusive
perdieron miembros de su cuerpo
a raíz de esta experiencia y muchas
otras en mi país decidí dedicar mi vida
al estudio de los derechos humanos los
derechos que son intrínsecos a cada
persona en este planeta por el simple
hecho de ser un ser humano sin embargo
quise ir más allá de lo que todos se
imaginan o entienden cuando hablamos de
estudiar derechos humanos que es el
aspecto jurídico y el aspecto político
de esto mi interés era entender que
podíamos hacer nosotros los ciudadanos
de la piel para hacer respetar nuestros
derechos humanos cuando vivimos en
entornos que no los garantizan
gracias a esto fue que descubrí lo que
hoy es mi razón de ser que es la
no-violencia más allá de un lema de vida
como una técnica socio política para
hacer incidencia en la política pública
y en mi sociedad en nuestra sociedad
para cambiar nuestro entorno hacia una
hacia un futuro positivo
a medida que iba estudiando la
no-violencia como una técnica no solo
como filosofía me di cuenta de que esta
técnica existe desde el 500 antes de
cristo y hay más de 1000 casos
documentados de grupos son movimientos
sociales que han usado técnicas y
estrategias de no-violencia para cambiar
su social y sin embargo la mayoría no lo
aprendemos ni siquiera en el colegio
a medida que continuaba estudiando
también me enteré de que en el último
siglo tomando en cuenta todas las
revoluciones que han habido son el 23
por ciento de las que eran violentas
tenían éxito mientras que el 50 por
ciento o más el doble de esta cantidad
que usaban técnicas de no-violencia
lograban tener éxito y llegar a su meta
final para instalar un cambio positivo
en su social
lo lindo es que en el año y en el punto
de la historia en el que estamos hoy ya
hay personas que han dedicado su vida a
estudiar esta técnica a entender que
protestas sueltas o tácticas sueltas por
cambiar nuestra realidad no van a
funcionar si no hay una estrategia por
detrás pero que sin necesidad de acudir
a la violencia sin necesidad de agredir
a otra persona oa otra entidad nosotros
sí podemos cambiar nuestra sociedad
a medida que fui aprendiendo más sentí
la necesidad de compartirlo pero cuando
empecé en este peregrinaje para hablar
de la no-violencia me encontré con
muchas puertas cerradas y con muchos
motivos por los cuales supuestamente no
puede ser efectiva una estrategia de la
violencia en nuestra sociedad como una
sociedad boliviana y latinoamericana
entonces al día de hoy quiero ir más
allá de los conceptos básicos de la
violencia y contarles los tres puntos
específicos que siempre me repiten por
los cuales supuestamente la no violencia
no puede ser efectiva para nosotros y
también quiero explicarles que están
errados
el primero se concentra en el adversario
he escuchado muchas veces que las
técnicas de no violencia así le
funcionaron a gandhi pero es que luchaba
contra los ingleses esto no habría
funcionado por ejemplo con un gobierno o
con un oponente tan represivo como la
alemania nazi
sin embargo esta concepción parte de una
idea equivocada de que es la
no-violencia con la no-violencia como
una técnica con la estrategia no estamos
buscando sólo cambiar la opinión
solamente de nuestro oponente eso es un
error que pensar que es así de simple o
básico algunos nos gusta hacerlo en el
proceso pero gravedad lo que estamos
buscando es generar suficiente tensión
social para que aquellas injusticias que
el status quo ignora puedan salir a la
superficie son gratas decía que hay que
crear tensión en la mente de un
individuo para que pueda elevar su
pensamiento de pensamientos
superficiales a un análisis crítico y es
eso lo que hace no violencia busca
levantarnos desde la injusticia desde la
discriminación desde muchos errores que
puede cometer nuestra sociedad pero
poder hablar de inclusión de igualdad de
justicia de todos estos temas que al
status quo no les convienen que surjan
un ejemplo que me encanta dar para este
caso justamente siempre va a encontrar
el ejemplo que me dan por el cual no
puede funcionar un tema que muy pocas
veces se nos enseña en las clases de
historia es que durante la alemania nazi
en la segunda guerra mundial la única
protesta que fue exitosa fue una
protesta hecha por mujeres en la calle
de la rosa' rosenstrasse en berlín en
1943 más de 400 mujeres mantuvieron una
protesta no violenta bajo cero en un
ambiente bastante peligroso para ellas
porque como pueden ver habían bastante
fuerzas de seguridad alrededor y con su
persistencia e insistirá no violenta
lograron liberar a más de mil judíos que
iban a ser deportados a campos de
concentración
una segunda razón que siempre escucho
con las cuales supuestamente la
no-violencia como una técnica no puede
funcionar en latinoamérica es porque
tenemos una sociedad demasiado violenta
y acostumbrada a la violencia y esto se
entiende porque inclusive a veces se usa
la violencia como una forma para educar
en casa a los niños sin embargo aquí
tenemos que darnos cuenta que cuando
hablamos de defender derechos humanos
muchas veces muchos grupos que se
organizan alrededor de una causa van a
tener una contraparte que quizás está
luchando por exactamente los mismos
derechos pero están usando métodos
violentos nunca va a ser una pelea única
a ese grupo pero es en ese momento en el
que nosotros como ciudadanos tenemos que
tomar la decisión de qué voy a hacer yo
para defender esta causa para defender
los derechos humanos sea el enfoque que
estudiando tenemos generalmente lo que
muchos creen dos opciones no hacer nada
porque así es la vida así es el mundo
las cosas no van a cambiar para que
arriesgarme
actuar de forma violenta participar en
una insurrección violenta agredir a mi
oponente o usar técnicas de guerrilla la
no-violencia plantea un punto en el
medio que no es radical y que busca
generar acciones que son exitosas que
son legítimas y al mismo tiempo que
pueden dar un resultado sin desgastar a
la gente en el proceso de participar en
estas protestas hay muchos beneficios de
actuar de esta forma pero para este caso
en específico quisiera recalcar 21 que
actuar de forma no violenta le dará
mucha legitimidad al mensaje que uno
está manejando porque demuestra que está
dispuesto a vivir su propuesta desde su
protesta y número 2 que al usar no
violencia y al tener protestas que son
alegres que son festivas a veces se hace
la burla de las chicas que se ponen
flores en el pelo o que le entregan
flores a su oponente no creen ustedes
que es mucho más fácil identificar a un
infiltrado del bando contrario que
quiera iniciar violencia dentro de
nuestras filas hay muchos beneficios
para evitar
y un tercer argumento el cual estoy
segura que muchos entienden es
justamente el machismo y aquí puedo
decir a nivel personal que como una
mujer joven y soltera que estoy
intentando transmitir este mensaje me
encontrado con muchas puertas cerradas
específicamente por esto pero al mismo
tiempo quiero contarles de que la forma
de desmantelar el machismo justamente se
encuentra dentro de las bases de la
no-violencia porque cuando hay una
sociedad que están fuertemente machista
o quizás no tanto se aprende de esto a
través de las interacciones sociales en
ambientes violentos en el que yo tengo
que ser por el agresor
el fuerte o la víctima lo cual es
vergonzoso cuando hablamos de
no-violencia hablamos de cambiar desde
nuestras creencias de que es poder que
es fuerza una fuerza inteligente a cómo
vamos a demostrarlo y usarlo para
cambiar la sociedad
una muy buena noticia que tengo respecto
a esto no es sólo de que han habido
casos de éxito de no violencia en
sociedades machistas y hoy en sé que
esperan que diga eso si no tiene habido
casos de éxitos de no violencia en
nuestra sociedad y esto se dio en 1977
cuando un grupo de cuatro mujeres
empezaron una huelga de hambre en la paz
que no sólo terminó torciendo el brazo
del dictador para darles perdón a los
presos políticos y a los exiliados que
habían cientos que pudieron retornar
sino que también generó que en un par de
años se tengan que llamar a elecciones
democráticas
si ellas pudieron hacerlo y eran solo
cuatro porque nosotros que somos muchos
ahora luchando por distintas causas no
podemos hacerlo y aquí quiero hablar de
algo muy importante que decía el doctor
martin luther king
martín decía que uno de los mayores
obstáculos para el avance de la sociedad
no es necesariamente el oponente que
quiere mantener el status quo sino las
personas de buena voluntad que entienden
nuestra causa pero que no quieren
participar en movimientos no violentos
porque porque estoy de acuerdo con tu
fin pero no me gusta el desorden que
genera una protesta no violenta qué
mensaje nos están dando en ese momento
que prefieren que el orden a la justicia
la justicia y el orden existen en una
sociedad para que nuestros derechos se
respeten cuando nuestros derechos no son
respetados son el mayor obstáculo para
que estos derechos se respeten entonces
lo que hay que entender es que un
entendimiento superficial de personas de
buena voluntad es aún más dañino que el
total de ese entendimiento de nuestro
oponente
y el día de hoy quiero invitarles a que
la próxima que vean una protesta y vean
que es no violenta obtengan una causa
por la cual quieren trabajar se sumen se
sumen porque al final del día si no
somos muchos y si no hay unión no se
puede lograr este cambio muchas personas
piensan esta causa es demasiado temprano
para que funciona en nuestra sociedad
aún no ha llegado el momento porque
piensan que con el tiempo estos avances
se van a dar pero todavía no es el
tiempo pero el tiempo es neutro el
tiempo no es algo que asegura el éxito
de un movimiento porque así el tiempo es
ahora y el tiempo puede ser constructivo
o destructivo en la medida en que yo no
participo para hacer que mi sociedad
mejore entonces los invito a que
busquemos la propuesta en la protesta
para que seamos valientes que sepamos
howard por aquellos que no pueden
hacerlo y por sobre todo que entendamos
que unos cuantos activistas o unas
cuantas personas luchando por una causa
no pueden cambiar el mundo
ayuda de cada uno de nosotros porque al
final del día como nos han enseñado a
muchos desde la cuna la unión es la
fuerza
[Aplausos]